[Music]
okay everybody I am so excited today
because I am joined by Elsie Fitcher and
Amaya Miller who's star in My Best
Friend's exorcism which is out tomorrow
on Prime video how you guys doing today
be good yeah
yeah great yeah that's great to hear I'm
so excited to talk to you guys and Elsie
having been in Castle Rock and now Texas
chainsaw and now with this you're
building up quite the strong horror
resume are you a big fan of the genre as
well like just watching horror yeah yeah
I mean I feel like part of that is
um you know the movies that really
affected me when I was younger was like
watching signs uh when I was way too
young and that freaked me out
um but also I you know kind of having
fallen into like doing horror films I
feel like uh it's been sort of my duty
to study up a bit yeah no and you do a
great job in them so it's exciting to
see you thank you a lot more horror now
Amaya playing a character who is
possessed in this film is that as fun as
it looks or is it a pretty dark head
space you're in
uh looking back it was fun this was one
of the most fun movies I've ever done
but definitely in the moment because I
am a perfectionist and I wanted to do a
good job and I wanted to be proud of my
work I did kind of tap into a dark
headspace
the scenes with the exorcism and stuff
like that I really released a lot of
like pent-up like feelings and anger and
stuff so I think it was actually very
beneficial that I was in that dark place
but I was indeed now that's cool to hear
and you really do a great job and you
you bring those scenes so much more
intensity to it which is great and no
problem Elsie you and Amaya also have
some great emotional scenes together so
what's the process like for building
trust with you and Amaya to pull off
these scenes I mean I I think we kind of
just right off the bat had like you know
a very sweet Bond and that kind of just
only grew stronger throughout filming
and
and I don't know I mean a lot of the
emotional scenes we have
um are not only sort of vulnerable for
the characters but I think just very
vulnerable topics in general that would
really require the you know friendship
that the two of them have so that stuff
I mean it I don't know it felt very real
on the day and that and that hopefully
led to both of our performances
yeah and I love that about this film
that there was those very real moments
that people can relate to and you guys
really do it with ease now Amaya do you
toss and turn at night before the day
you have to film a big scene like an
exorcism is that something that you get
nervous about or embrace it I didn't
even sleep last night because I had to
do this today
so exorcism scenes that's even worse no
I don't sleep and it's so annoying
anytime I have something to do or
something I care about is the next day I
it it's I might as well like drink an
energy drink like yeah just keep the
train rolling yeah yeah
I love that I'm sure you probably
transfer that into your performance too
which is kind of cool if I'm guessing
right but yeah I was so tired that I
just it was easier to cry
I love that oh now Elsie Switching gears
a bit I'm super jealous you post on
Instagram couple months ago you got sent
gifts from Nintendo
um have you had the chance to play Zelda
breath of the wild it is it as good as
they say that's the question I have for
you oh definitely breath of the wild I
think that's like one of the I that was
one of the first games I got on my
switch
um uh and I really didn't touch it for a
long time because I wasn't like a Zelda
fan and then I fell so deeply into it
um and that was one of the things I
played on set a lot for this I always
had my switch and I would do like Mario
I I always had a little switch her
switch and a notebook to write whatever
she was thinking or did little Doodles
she was so cute and I would just I know
I was listening to music
it's like
I love that
um now Amaya at such a young age being
really the poster you know face for this
huge film and War of the Planet of the
Apes or for the Planet of the Apes is
there something you learned from that
experience that you've kind of taken
with you with these projects you're
doing now
oh my gosh yeah so much of everything I
know now is because of that movie I
worked with some of the most incredible
actors and even like the Press tour that
I went on from that you know like stuff
like this it helps me with that so many
lessons were learned because of that and
so many friendships were made and
it's kind of I was talking about this
the other day because I did that when I
was 11 and kind of new to this industry
and it just set the bar for everything
else and
yeah so it's that movie has such a
special place in my heart I love it
that's awesome yeah and it's a great
movie and everyone loves that movie make
sure to check out Amaya and I'll see
crush it like they always do in My Best
Friend's exorcism which is out tomorrow
on Prime video thank you guys for
joining me today and I hope to talk to
you in the future yeah thank you man